[Music]
we love working with all kinds of
animals
but every once in a while something
comes along that gets
everybody really excited we got llamas
coming today
like this is like a jackpot day
[Music]
hey how are you doing good good to see
you how are you i'm doing great
the llamas are rare in nebraska and
today we have three llamas coming in all
at once
so this is your herd so far so far so
far
brian's wife and i have been lifelong
friends
and while at the nebraska state fair
last year we decided hey let's kind of a
mid-life crisis and
buy some llamas i can't wait to meet
your babies
i went to the state fair and there are
these llamas and they drew me in
and hypnotized me and i knew that was it
i just had to have a llama
that's temptress hi pretty girl we used
to call you temptress in college didn't
we shut up you did not
there is golden boy and that's thunder
you are cool so our lovely lady lama
was bred earlier this year and she's
here today to see if she's pregnant
the llama's on parade but first a round
of vaccines and dewormer for the whole
crew
okay guys ready i'm gonna pinch a little
bit good boy okay
good all right all right now we'll give
him his dewormer
i'm glad he threw all three llamas in
because they're packed animals
they like the comfort of each other good
all right
one down okay ready boys ready guys hold
on boy hold on
llamas are kind of wiggly to hang on to
hold on didn't like that did you no
and she by far is the most sensitive to
being handled oh great
or do you want to just try her in the
stall ben yeah
she has more manpower than we do so
we're going to put her in a safe place
and get her done safely do you go into
the padded room
easy come in hey good girl easy girl
little baby good girl hold it hold on
good
oh the rodeo
got those big old long necks
i think i want to get you yeah spit on
you and then when you're not looking and
you're moving away from my spin i'm
going to kick you out
yeah they're very powerful for their
size that's for sure see
shoot that chicken bite easy girl
getting her boy that don't sound good
oh there you go you okay yeah well we're
gonna give her a little more
she spit half it out
so you had your worming for the year
temptress is being a typical llama
i've done a lot of horses they never do
that
[Music]
a llama's natural defense mechanism is
to actually take their stomach contents
and regurgitate it right at you a
llama's spit can travel up to 15 feet
there good good girl now we get to see
if she's gonna be a mama
we're gonna have to put on the
ultrasound and get a picture here this
is the screen that you're gonna be able
to watch and you can just hold this
you'll see everything i'm seeing okay
all right all right and the most
definitive thing to see
would be to really any part of the baby
but a heartbeat would be the best
because then we know the baby's viable
it's alive and everything is gonna be
a-okay hopefully we're hoping for a
positive result
it's okay gotta move slow she's doing so
good
i'm not seeing anything obvious guys
it's not a good sign really all i see is
food material at this point
we could draw blood on her if we're
inconclusive but it's more gratifying
just to ultrasound her belly and see if
we can see that baby
one more try we're gonna keep looking
cause i don't like to give up
in llamas there is less amniotic fluid
proportionately
surrounding that kriya which is a baby
llama it's not just
like a lady that's like yep it's right
here you got to kind of go on a little
bit of a hunt
to figure out where she's tucking this
baby if there is one there
i think i see something now when i get
further down
that looks i know like a heartbeat right
there that's
going right there mm-hmm 100 she's
pregnant that looks like a creature
[Applause]
you better have a little baby so
exciting
she's about nine months along and their
gestation is 11 months to 12 months and
i've heard even 13 months so that's kind
of crazy that they can hold these babies
inside them over a year
this is the most wonderful thing to
happen to us now we know that we're
going to have a baby coming in a few
months
and then we can start thinking about
building a larger herd from that good
girl mama
you are an official mama llama
i decided to rain today we're at an
unusual house call today
hey it's good to see you our good client
mary
has some concerns about a neighborhood
cat she cares for she can't get near
this cat to get it to the clinic
so she needs our expert cat catching
help this one heck of a house call
oh you betcha well i feel like i brought
like my team of ninjas
we appreciate how well dr ben and erin
take care of cats cats of course are the
most important patients they see what's
going on with this kid here can you give
me the back story
sure spot is one of the neighborhood
cats
we have house cats and we have what we
call garage cats
who will come by for food water and a
warm dry place to sleep
i've seen him eat recently and he licks
very carefully
at wet food and he'll take like a half a
bite but he never really closes his
mouth
it possibly likes canned food because
his mouth hurts scale of one to ten
you know one being like you could sleep
with him in your bed and ten being like
he would be right about a seven or an
eight
oh he's pretty feral then never touch
this cat
because this cat lives on the streets
with no particular owner
we have to assume that it's unvaccinated
let's get some long sleeves on this guy
okay you've got long sleeves i will go
get some
it's a great idea to wear long sleeves
and gloves to protect ourselves
just in case this kitty's claws come out
if they scratch you or bite you
kitties can transmit bacteria through
those wounds
these are like very tiny gloves i can't
get them you want to get them off
got giant hands man five-year-olds mom i
can't even get my hands
i think they're married she has like
normal lady-sized hands
oh i see his face he's right down there
oh yeah
yeah he could come zipping out of there
at any moment what if we put
the carrier we can just grab his torso
no he's not he's wild we can't just kick
him up he's never been touched
i like your plan guys open up the front
of the carrier
to this side yep maybe we'll stick a
broom down the other side and just kind
of scoot him from the back and
see if he goes forward because i want to
stick this along the back side
honey that might spook him well i know
but what am i going to do that's the
whole plan
i think you should just sort of gently
lay something there
there's a lot of ideas going on here
okay let's get that carrier right in
that spot erin
let's see what happens push him did he
go in he's looking at me
he doesn't want to really go in go in
he's headed out the other way turn
around
here we go he's moving backing up a
little backing
watch up honey get in
mary are you gonna try it yeah okay come
on spot
that's a good kitty
that's a good kitty
got it good job ta-da
wow it's okay let's go cover that thing
up
how about that athletic move on that
post how about the athletic movie your
mother
and that's why i went to college on a
basketball scholarship
i'm really glad that you take care of
these kitties and love them like you do
they're lucky to have you as their
caregivers
mary is sort of like our fairy cat
mother
and spot is a patient who is really
benefiting from her generosity
hey val hi i brought you a present
this is mary's kitty her name is spot
don't know if it's a he or she
but it is a true feral the kitty is not
chewing and eating properly
so i think the safest thing is to sedate
it in the carrier and then
get him or her out
[Music]
val and i have done this for a long time
where we have hero cats come in and we
just sort of rotate the carrier and get
the kitties so they're sitting
on a spot we can get a syringe through
and poke quickly and easily
by the time they realize something's
happened it's already all over so
your butt comes here kitty that's what
we want this carrier trick helps reduce
the stress on the kitty
because she's not used to being handled
she's a feral cat and it will also
really help protect val and i
we don't know this cat's history and so
i don't want either of us to get bitten
got it good job while i'm prepping for
spots exam
ben is catching up with a farmer who has
a newborn calf with a life-threatening
condition
oh pretty calf and a pretty pink blanket
yep i'm here because i've got a very
special calf that
has a hernia wow this is a big hernia
yeah
she was born like this she'll be three
days old today
so normally we've got our strong body
wall holding all of our organs
in she unfortunately has a rent or a
hole in her abdominal wall
and that is allowing all these organs to
just spill out
well charlie have you ever seen a hernia
that big i've only seen
like you do two or three of them they're
only like the size of a tennis ball
this one is huge yeah this is more like
a volleyball literally it's
big this hole in her abdomen
is it's big
there's one edge and there's the other
edge
that's about three or four inches across
so it's large
basically the risks involved in this
surgery are
there's going to be so much tension on
my stitches from when she starts eating
again
and really feeling good that they can
start breaking down and then we have
another hernia
in people we sometimes get two or three
tries and
in animals we usually get one try and
that's it she's probably got a 50 50
chance even if everything goes well with
surgery
of making it
this is a big hernia repairing this
calf's hernia is risky
but it's her only chance at life she's
probably got a 50 50 chance even if
everything goes well with surgery
of making it 50 is better than nothing
you know
we've got to try something i put my
whole trust in ben
i've had been on my farm four years now
and i feel very confident
because good people take care of good
people is what i always like to say
charlie let's roll her into the other
room and then i'm gonna start getting
ready for surgery
okay
okay now the spot's falling asleep
we can take a look from tip to tail and
see if we can figure out why she's not
eating
i'm just gonna look here first at these
teeth
oh let me smell that mm-hmm
uh it smells like infection yucky kitty
she's got some bad teeth darn it
you know we've got some tartar some
gingivitis
we'll just clean them and see what we
have underneath that tartar and what
needs to come out okay
well preparing spot for surgery i'm
noticing much more than rotten teeth
ooh so she has these ulcerations on the
back of her tongue and her throat
see that oh yeah so what
what is causing that the ulcers on the
back of spot's tongue
are really indicating that there's an
infection present
if left untreated this infection could
really make it tough for spot to chew
and swallow
food we definitely need to run blood
work to find out more
okay blood blood blood
we need to move quickly while spots
under anesthesia so val's going to get
spot steno started and i'm going to take
her blood work and see if we have any
other conditions flying under the radar
okay aaron so when i was cleaning here
you got a
lower molar here pretty painful
on you oh oh yep there's a little
resorptive lesion
it's hitting that nerve and making her
jaw kind of jump around a little so
that's kind of back where that lesion
was on her tongue those sores
so i'm wondering if she's really having
an issue that that tooth is causing that
infection
it's irritating her tongue so let's get
that tooth out of here we'll get her an
injectable antibiotic
and some pain medicines great news her
blood work is totally normal so she's a
nice
healthy cat as far as her organs are
concerned if you can get ready i'll cut
that tooth and
get it pulled
well i'm just gonna cut the gum away
okay perfect
i got the tooth split and
here we go there's that back root
this decayed tooth and the infection on
her tongue are definitely the cause of
spots issues
it's a great thing that mary noticed
that spot was eating funny
because this infection could have taken
over in her mouth and then who knows
what might have happened
all right me spotty now spock can return
to a pain-free life on the prowl
okay i'll call mary
a good deed was done
i'm gonna give her her pre-meds
okay she's definitely out now we're
gonna go right into surgery
oh he's got the calf all clean ready for
surgery
aaron luckily is gonna help me look at
that mom
look at it when she breathes now it goes
erp out the hole
this is actually one of the biggest
hernias i've ever repaired if we did
nothing this calf would probably
lay around for two or three months and
some of the intestines would probably
get stuck down into the hernia
and then the calf can't poop anymore and
she would die
[Music]
okay guys here goes my incision
this is actually an elliptical incision
around the hernia
is that tougher than making a normal
straight line it is
kind of got to be an artiste it gets rid
of some of the extra tissue right away
and it gives me a baseline of exactly
where to be
for the repair okay so i've got my
elliptical incision here
and now i'm gonna cut that skin all out
your hole's gonna get scary big
i know it is
that's an enormous hole not the one
you're making the one in her cup
did you feel it yeah mm-hmm like you
could park a truck in that thing
too big wow this is all those intestines
right here that's a lot mm-hmm
she's pushing up on my hole quite a bit
does it make it tougher when those
intestines are popping up it does
so what i got here is muscle way over
here
yeah and way over here those edges are
very far apart from each other
what i need to do is there and have you
glove in and hold that okay
so i'm going to clamp these together
this is going to make or break the whole
surgery right here
this is going to make or break the whole
surgery right here
aaron and i are in surgery with a
three-day old calf this poor baby has
the largest hernia i've ever worked on
we got to get from here over to there
and we got to freshen it what i mean by
freshen the edges is i'm going to
actually cut along them
and get some live cells bleeding and
when we sew that together
that has a chance of actually being one
piece of tissue again
there we're going i'd say we saw that
first half such a big hole
right in the middle where i put the
towel clamp to hold the two pieces of
body wall together that's ground zero
aaron and i decided let's do half of it
first
and then we work from the back up to the
towel clamp so we met in the middle
and if one of those would break we still
have half of it that's holding it
okay so we've got the top half sewn
together now we got to work on the
bottom half
okay this is gonna be a little tricky
okay there's interesting right below
there
when she exhales is gonna be the key
not now okay go okay
that was good bite one more okay
you first have to close the body wall
then you close the subcutaneous layer
and then you close the skin after that a
three-layer closure has more strength
and stability than if you were just to
close everything all in one
big swoop that looks pretty good thanks
for your help
you betcha baby i've just fixed the
biggest hernia i've ever fixed in my
whole career
but just because this surgery went well
doesn't mean this calf's in the clear
tomorrow she'll go home and recover on
the farm austin will have to keep her
clean and dry
to make sure she doesn't eat too much
and stretch out that new belly
hey honey hi i need to talk with you
on something you know what i'm really
kind of missing
is a dog a dog i was thinking maybe it
would be a good thing
for the boys maybe to have some chores
this might even be for us they're going
to be out of the house soon
so yeah we might need a companion
ourselves i'll have to just talk to you
we don't want that you on board i am
aaron is often asking about new animals
we always are talking about getting a
new pet
but it's tough to do because we work a
lot but
i don't really think there's any
stopping her this time what do you got
in mind
well oh you've been searching already
this is a real thing yeah you know me i
like to online shop but
chase and i kind of were looking and i
found one named bud
bud looks nice he just came available
for adoption this can be the one
come on mom's here spa has recovered
wonderfully after her surgery yesterday
hi mary hello she's eating well she's
gone to the bathroom and she is ready
to return to the great outdoors your cat
radar was
on fire and she did have a tooth with a
resort deletion that very sensitive
portion of the tooth was exposed so we
did remove that
molar she did have some associated sores
on the back of her tongue and on her
throat that were sort of infection
treated her with a two-week antibiotic
so you don't have to give her anything
which is great
she also has pain medication on board
that'll last another 12 hours
she is very feral but she's very kind
you can release her into the garage and
if you can keep her in there for another
day or two just to make sure she's
eating drinking
sure i'm sure she's just scared and
tired
she had one of the worst days of her
life yesterday but it's also one of the
best days of her life
exactly i really do believe left
untreated she would have deteriorated
i'm grateful that you took care of her
i'm great she's grateful for available
to come help
get her well it just worked out perfect
i worried about her last night and
it's great to have her back and headed
back home
please keep us posted on how she does i
will okay thanks see ya
[Music]
we just got a call from a client who has
a jack russell terrier
that had two seizures i told him
immediately to load the dog up and let's
get here the dog
may walk in normal or he could come in
completely flat
and i think i actually just heard him
come in
[Music]
he's having a seizure right now watch
your fingers
how long have you had him it's been a
couple months
and no seizures before no i've never
seen him do this before
this dog is a recent adoption and its
medical history is a complete
unknown i'm gonna have val grab
anti-seizure meds will i run blood work
we've got to start some diagnostics to
see what's going on and what's causing
this this is not a good situation
all right pal you got him okay it's all
right buddy
pal you got him okay i'm gonna get blood
running first okay it's all right buddy
we're looking for clues as to why rascal
is seizing the blood work will give us
information on his organ function and
electrolytes
and the other diagnostics will hopefully
point us to a cause
oh let's go ahead and get an iv catheter
in him you're right
you're all right rascal well we wait for
the blood work results we're going to
get a catheter in for supportive care
caitlin hold onto his butt
rascal this is an important step rascal
please be good and hold still
okay we adopted him two months ago we
haven't seen any seizure activity unless
we've had him so
what caused it how do we make this
little happy little dog
be a happy little dog have you done any
fertilizer or anything for the crops
anything at all like that the neighbor
just did the
side but the neighbor did do a fungicide
yeah
okay that's right there let's be here
i'm thinking because he's never had
seizures before and has had three this
morning
that there is potentially some sort of
ingestion he's a farm dog
so there are a zillion things that are
around a farm that can be poisonous to
dogs please don't work
i just knew something was wrong what's
gonna happen to this little dog
everything is completely normal on his
blood work his glucose is okay
his liver enzymes are okay his kidneys
are okay i feel like ingestion or
toxicity is a little lower down the list
i think i'd like to just check x-rays
since we've never had a seizure
there's no other great answer that i
have
he's always been able to see you right
yeah he's never had any issues with that
as i'm taking a look at rascal i'm
noticing that something is up with his
vision
that's abnormal he's not visual right
now there could be something going on
might be more of a seizure stroke
certainly that but it could also be
mass brain tumor i mean there's there's
a lot of things we may not see anything
that could
suddenly cause that issue okay well
let's go get this taken
lori could you give ben a call yeah
thank you ben's our eye expert
so while i'm taking these x-rays i'm
gonna have him come take a look and make
sure that i'm not missing something
logan x-rays really nothing abnormal
there
he's good yeah empty tummy so
good things lots of good things i don't
see a large tumor we'll just get him
settle down and
have ben look at his eyes
[Music]
he's not painful he his x-rays look fine
his cervical
vertebrae looked fine with the vision
loss is weird that doesn't really go
with ingestion
and he's not vomiting you know most
these things make them sick to their
belly he's not giving us very many hints
as to what's going on here
[Music]
everything looks great there it doesn't
look
abnormal at all you know hemorrhage in
the eye yeah let's say we have
no vision from pressure on the optic
nerves yeah
i mean that's very possible yeah we need
some non-steroidal anti-inflammatories
to
counteract that these meds will help
reduce the swelling that may be
affecting his vision
but the good news is we've ruled out
everything else that we can
so this has got to be epilepsy i think
we have to treat him like an epileptic
we need to control these seizures it's
supportive care and wait and see
yeah okay let's start with that
epilepsy is a condition you diagnose by
exclusion
and i feel very confident that we've
ruled out all these other culprits that
could be causing these seizures
so we're gonna start rascal on
anti-seizure meds and we're gonna have
our intern caitlin
sit with him this afternoon and monitor
for any breakthrough seizures
caitlin i think we put him in that
kennel and he's gonna really get upset
so whatever chair you wanna sit in
you want intern plus plus duties is to
sit out and hang out with him and you're
on seizure watch if he has a seizure
what do i need to do
[Music]
chase and i are heading out to austin's
farm for a checkup on his calf
the hernia surgery went really well hey
austin how's it going
but we truly won't know until we can get
a good look at that belly
make sure the sutures are holding tight
and everything is where it should be
and that's inside oh she's kicking today
we got a little different calf here
today don't we awesome a little bit from
the last time you said
that's good okay i'm gonna carefully not
trying to get kicked on your side
okay ready go there we go chase wants
you to come around here
help me hold legs good
all right you know really we've got some
beautiful healing that's happened here
we've got just a little bit of a area
where the sutures are reacting and
that's okay
you know these two spots here that's
where our big knots were
this is just scar tissue this incision
went from here
all the way down to here and it looks
great i mean we just pulled her out of
the yard
you know it's a rainy day there's a
little bit of mud on it but it's healing
up and it's closing for what she's gone
through and with the big surgery she's
had
all of her guts and intestine and all
those abdominal contents
they have no chance of coming out
anymore and that's the important thing
here this is
a win you know yeah we did a life-saving
surgery and um
now she can go live out her life it
wasn't very good odds but
i'm glad we beat the odds so glad to
save her life thank you thank you
[Music]
good job charlie thanks dad i'm actually
working
a lot of book work when you're a vet you
know that right it seems like you're
always doing something over there
detainees are here wonder what they got
the taney boys are kind of like the tom
sawyers and hug fins of this town
ty trev and miles anytime they show up
you just know they've got themselves
into something
charlie you got to see that oh boy
what do you got in there let's take a
look a band of local brothers
has come into the clinic and what
they've brought in is wild
literally little baby raccoon we found
the raccoon in our shop
on our farm it's a wild animal and we
didn't really know what to do with it
they're one of those species where we
kind of think they're nuisances
or these little guys that tear apart our
garbage cans
but it's helpless it's an orphan we need
to take care of this a little raccoon
a raccoon is a wild animal they can
carry this parasite that
is not very good for people to get so we
want to all put on gloves and then we'll
take a look here okay the round worm is
shed by
raccoons just kind of like dogs and cats
but their specific roundworm
if it gets into a human can migrate
through your body and go into really
weird places like your eyes or your
brain
set it right there it's definitely
something you don't want to mess around
with
it can be fatal
[Music]
oh my goodness hi
all right let's see what we're dealing
with a boy or a girl
okay looks to be a little girl raccoon
guys
any names so far yet ricky ricky okay
ricky can work for a girl oh my goodness
she's trying to nurse anything she can
she's hungry
let's mix up some kitten milk replacer
and we'll definitely want to get her
de-worm too
every veterinarian in my opinion needs
to take care of any of these animals
that come in our door
how's that bottle coming charlie good
i'm almost done
we get caught up a lot in trying to make
our business
make money and do things that pay our
bills and feed us wildlife doesn't do
that
but it is an obligation in our
profession this is the
dewormer oh it's not mountain
it's not enough all right
that was easy wasn't it guys yeah let's
see if this little baby will nurse
oh she's figuring it out oh look at how
hungry it is
ty i think you can handle this you want
to hold her yeah
i don't think she's given that up for
nothing ty you should
maybe think about uh going into this
field you kind of know how to do that
i think the smartest thing to do with a
wild animal like this would be to
have somebody who's really proficient in
taking care of them
do that i don't know we should i kind of
want to keep it
you must have more of your mom in you
than what i thought and uh
the answer is no the taney boys are
going to take this little raccoon to the
animal refuge center
and they should be able to take care of
this little raccoon until it's
released into the wild which is great
why not try to save a life right
it's awesome
[Music]
all right it's okay i know
your mommy's here our patient rascal
came into the clinic in critical
condition after a string of seizures
after 24 hours of observation and
treatment we're sending him home
but he's not out of the woods yet
[Music]
there's been no more seizures since he's
been here all the blood work came back
completely normal i think he's a little
more visual
oh he's definitely that's better are you
yawning there's really
no other reason we can find you know
that leaves basically
epilepsy i want you to keep him on
epileptic meds to treat his seizures
a brain tumor is sort of worst case
scenario so we would treat with
epileptic drugs and
certainly if that did not resolve it
then you know have other conversations
you know stay on top stay on top of that
i'm hopeful
but i definitely want to check up on him
in a few weeks to see how the treatment
is working
oh he's definitely loved so logan has a
birthday picture to show you
oh yeah when was your birthday not mars
yes
oh look at him in his sumo outfit for
his birthday
well call me if you need me okay bye
buddy okay
all right thank you thank you okay okay
[Music]
hi ready morning guys good my goodness
those are the prettiest bunnies
ever um you guys just want to go into
two
okay olivia and her mom are here with a
ton of bunnies that she raised for her
4-h project
so this is a health paper for your fair
right yes i've been a 4-h member for
about four years
i brought my bunnies to the clinic here
today to get their normal health check
out for the fair
otherwise they can't be a member of the
fair and that's what i do
it's bunny time programs help teach
kids about leadership and commitment to
their communities this is jack a holland
lop
because of his lap ears yes we're just
checking to make sure none of these
animals have any signs of infectious
disease
sounds great we don't want anybody
bringing something to the fair that
they're going to share with their
neighbor
what breed is this one the lionhead
cutest thing i've ever seen
in my life oh my gosh funny we have to
get one that's house trained
lungs sound great the lion head is a
breed of rabbit that has a long mane of
fur around its head
their origin is unknown but who cares
they are the cutest things on the planet
just a tiny little bunny here nose looks
good
looking matches my shirt i know honey
there's more bunnies
i'm good
[Laughter]
this isn't a charlie cause he has a half
mustache are you a charlie
the half mustache comes from a broken
jean that's inherited from each parent
making these rabbits look like charlie
chaplin oh that's willie
good nose eyes look clear this is
buttercup she's a red-eyed white
how's that butt look that butt looks
great they've all got their normal hard
rabbit poops
good catch olivia sorry you're okay
i am totally impressed you really know
your animals and they are clean
they're well taken care of i love
raising them because it kind of gives me
like a feeling
of peace i spend so much time with them
it's just kind of like
my favorite thing to do now good luck my
dear meeting
totally same here and thank you for
bringing them down today
yeah sharing them
we got a late call from a dairy farmer
one of his milk cows has been sick for a
day or two
and hasn't improved he's starting to get
worried and rightfully so
when a cow doesn't eat it could mean a
number of serious issues
so erin and i are heading to the farm
with the boys to check her out
got it chase oh gosh hey mark
quite a storm we're having yeah okay
yeah
can you lead us to where she's at yep
[Music]
one thing i just noticed is she's kind
of straining
okay you know not much fecal material is
coming out so that means
something may be twisted internally i'll
take a quick listen here and see what we
got
chase can i show you this just want you
to listen to it
i'm gonna ping real hard against your
abdomen
[Music]
what's it sound like like a basketball
it's full of air
so it sounds like a displaced abomasum a
displaced abomasum or more commonly
called a da
is the fourth stomach of a cow that is
shifted out of place
it always occurs from them not eating
for a day or two
and then gas building up in the stomach
where there's no food
holding it down into place eventually
they do die
the left d.a which is what she has is
fixable with a roll
okay okay you basically roll them on
their back get the abomasum right into
place
so we can fix her without going into her
abdomen and actually having
surgery okay which is a good thing for
her especially
on a night like this i'm glad i brought
everybody along in the family because
now we have lots of hands on deck
because we need to go cow-tipping okay
okay we'll lightly sedate her so she
doesn't fight us during the roll
okay and i'm gonna give it she's gonna
start going to sleep pretty quick so go
ahead and let her loose
we're gonna pull her down she has to
roll the correct way
right side legs over so that way the
stomach comes up to the top in the right
direction
as far as difficulty this is probably in
nine out of ten
i know a lot of veterinarians that don't
like to do this procedure because
it takes practice and luckily i had a
father who
taught me how to do it this is not
something i learned in vet school i
promise you that i learned it from john
schrader
okay here we go i'm gonna pull oh yeah
she's really bracing
come on girl
[Music]
we're gonna pull her down she has to
roll the correct way
okay here we go i'm gonna pull this
dairy cow has a displaced apple mason
that's basically a twisted stomach she's
really bracing
we're rolling her on her back to get
this stomach back into place
but this 1500 pound cow has got ideas of
her own
come on girl nope she's going there we
go
yes oh roll at your feet okay hold this
tight mark
well we're gonna push her over ready
good that's just like 1500 to 2 000
pound animal they aren't the best
breathers when they're on their
feet let alone on their back and so you
have to do this procedure quickly and
efficiently
it's dangerous for them now
go over to that other next post and give
it one wrap
i'm gonna pull and you're gonna pull i'm
gonna pull
you're gonna pull pull one more time
one more time
[Music]
all right that abba mason should be back
in place
so we're going to give her a lot of
sugar
right now all right i can still see a
vein that's good
so we want her to get back on her feet
soon and the sugar should really do that
all done with the fluids she's waking up
she's about ready time to wake you up
sugar's hitting come on girl
there you go get up girl you know what
your back feet are
now the next thing is she needs to help
herself she needs to go right back to
eating
and drinking and put a lot of weight in
that abba mesa
and that will hold it into place all
right i love that she's eating and
drinking
i'd say that that's a good sign i'm glad
we came out tonight i know it's wet and
cold but
morning could have been worse off yeah
thanks for coming tonight you bet
[Music]
so we're on our way to go see rascal who
is the
little doggie that we diagnosed with
epilepsy and just check in and see how
his meds are going
making sure that he's responding and
that he's comfortable and that mom and
dad are comfortable with all the
recommendations that we've given
it is windy
hello how are you
me and he looks good yeah well how's he
doing
good so far so far so good yeah eating
drinking
crying and how about his vision um so
far so good
and easy playing and being a happy dog
he's getting to be more and more
okay more social he doesn't chase the
cats as much
they did tip me extra for that
[Music]
you know it's really positive we haven't
seen any more seizures yes so absolutely
that is something i'll never forget
watching him go through and hopefully we
don't ever have to see it again
well i'm so glad i got to swing by today
i mean he's just a different dog he's
alert he's bright and he just looks he
just looks happy
you know my number you call me anytime
all right thank you
bye rascal
all right chase i think this is the day
hi guys we are in yankton south dakota
at the heartland humane society looking
for some dogs that
are available for adoption you have a
little
whip-it type dog it was adopted this one
yeah well i've got black cats and 10
other dogs back there
what do you got for dogs yeah let's go
look
all right so who you have in here
we've got nellie's new great pyrenees
really sweet sweet girl
oh she is sweet she's a little bit big a
little big for you
absolutely both riggs and winnie came in
in the last week
guys she's probably still growing though
she's only seven months old
i'm not sure i could carry you up the
stairs when you age look at how old are
you
two years do you have any little dogs
yeah the only two i have are paired
they've gotta go together well this is
the right size
this is happy in skittles hi guys
their owner just got too old so they're
looking for a fresh family to finish
life out with
they definitely are happy to see you
there's just something there i really
like about these two little dogs they're
kind of like the odd couple
do you like them yeah they're pretty
cute
it's but it's two it's two
oh my gosh i'm gonna end up a single
woman with two kids i have to take care
of you wanna get them out
yeah let's see let's get them out hi
guys
oh well aren't you convincing chase and
i love these little dogs happy
is awesome skittles is so snuggly and
cuddly
but it's still two dogs so this isn't a
decision to take lightly
oh he's snuggling you
[Music]
what's up let's go see what you got here
you stay here
hey hon how'd it go well
we got a dog oh he's awesome look at you
buddy
this is skittles skittles and
happy what two dogs two dogs
man i had no idea i was thinking she
might just go and look
we talked about one dog but two dogs
what happened here
these guys were a bonded pair
and they are eight and twelve oh wow i
like it so they're probably house broken
they're supposed to be house broken
they've been around kitties kids and you
had to take them both
we went up there to get bud and he had
been adopted
so carrie just kind of showed us what
she had and we fell in love how can you
not
love them look at him skittles you are
tricks
skittles you can do tricks what tricks
does he do huh do you sit
speak
doesn't he oh my god good dog i'm
actually really excited
thank you hey we have two kids we might
as well have two dogs yeah
all kidding aside i think skittles and
happy are going to be a wonderful
addition to our family
you like guys did chase and i do good
yes i am so happy that we have these two
new additions
a lot of times older dogs get overlooked
in a shelter situation
because they aren't playful puppies but
they need love and they need homes too
job number one potty pockets let's go
walk them out all right
come on happy come skittles good job
baby
we did it
you